[Music]
yeah berries nice fair and I'll just
turn lucky bear on right here hello I'm
Ricky bear what's your name
Conan O'Brien Conan O'Brien
irish-american talk-show host and former
writing partner of sitcom producer Greg
Daniels that's right yeah that's
fantastic yeah I can answer any question
you have
I'm Ricky bear okay wiki bear what's the
most successful movie ever released in
China checking now the 2014 film
transformers age of extinction has
earned over 1.7 billion dollars making
it China's biggest blockbuster ever yay
I wouldn't have guessed that Thank You
wiki bear speaking of explosive action
the ancient city of Pompeii was
completely destroyed by the eruption of
Mount Vesuvius which buried 20,000 Roman
citizens under scorching hot ash okay
that's interesting to know
imagine being burned alive in a literal
hell on earth with temperatures hot
enough to cook a rotisserie chicken make
by an extra crispy you
Wiki bear maybe we shouldn't get into
the details there for kids kids don't
want to hear that many of the victims
were Roman slaves what a gruesome end to
a miserable life i wakey all right well
anyway wicked birthday now their corpses
are on display for gawking tourists
robbed of dignity even in death let's
change the subject
here's another question okay when did
Disneyland first open that's easy the
happiest place on earth opened its doors
on July 17 1955 in Anaheim California
that's exactly right and you know who
never got to ride Space Mountain the
sailors on the whaleship Essex which was
attacked and sunk by an angry whale in
1820 the starving survivors quickly
resorted to cannibalism using the
scalding hot Sun to cook their own
shipmates organs a Twinkie bear okay
I've we should have stuck to Disneyland
I think that's yeah the captain even ate
his own cousin after promising the boy's
mother he protect him must have been an
awkward family reunion you okay Wicky
bear that's good we got it that kid went
from first mate to first me okay you're
doing jokes I got a million all right
listen
here's a question you can't turn into
something disturbing all right this is
just good who holds the record for most
hot dogs eaten in a single sitting that
delicious distinction goes to Takeru
Kobayashi who once ate 110 hotdogs in
just ten minutes okay that's nice and
that's incredible speaking of
record-breaking sausage the late porn
star John Holmes was famous for having
the industry's biggest penis
and the biggest cocaine habit desperate
for cash he and some friends robbed a
notorious coke dealer yay okay you know
what
this is not appropriate for kids so
remember kids never give a junkie your
real address I'm Ricky baby no kid is
even asking that question you brought
that up we didn't bring that up homes
died just a few years later alone and
penniless and now he's making porn in
heaven gave a boy okay that's enough
coke no no no one's making porn in
heaven
cocaine keeps youth in kitchener it's
fun to snort above what's your stomach
[Applause]
you